uh president biden keeping up with the
habit of avoiding reporters questions on
matters both foreign and domestic here's
what he did after making remarks on
what's going on with russia and ukraine
watch and for freedom
where it is at risk today
will surely pay a steeper price tomorrow
thank you i'll keep you informed
[Applause]
are
news contributor joe concha joins us
joe putting aside the fact that he took
0.0 questions on anything let's focus on
the topic of the press conference to
begin with this is a very rare event for
joe biden to do i.e a press conference
what do you make of his priorities when
he uses one of these opportunities to
talk about ukraine and not the daily
struggle that each and every one of us
is undergoing in the us when it comes to
crime when it comes to inflation and the
like
well i love two things here a you've
already worked in an animal house
reference with the 0.0 thing so thank
you dean wermer appreciate that i also
like the fact that joe biden said i'll
keep you informed okay the way you keep
people informed is by taking questions
that you answer and not just reading off
a teleprompter for 11 minutes in this
situation so i love the excuse that i
see by the way uh from from some people
on the left online defending mr biden on
not taking any questions because they
say hey he did a long press conference
in january uh yeah things change on a
day-to-day basis and the president
should be held accountable on a
day-to-day basis and when he makes
remarks like this he should at least
take questions from a few reporters
before bolting the stage like he's
cooper cup all right then i can
virtually guarantee you
that that during the state of the union
thank you todd uh in two weeks he will
not even broach how to fix the u.s
southern border or fixing bail laws or
even addressing the fentanyl crisis that
has killed more than a hundred thousand
people in this country last year it's
the leading cause of death for those
between 18 and 49 all foreign topics and
i doubt they're gonna be approaching the
state of the union and certainly it's
not gonna be a press conference between
now and then i will certainly take that
bet joe meanwhile totally unforced error
by mayor eric adams who
is mad at the press coverage he's
receiving over crime and then just
totally played the race card watch this
i'm a black man that's the mayor
but my story has been interpreted by
people that don't look like me
how many blacks are in the editorial
boards
how many blacks have determined how
these stories are being written
everybody talks about my government
being diversified
what's the first diversification in the
newsrooms
so i guess the question is do you need
to be the same race as a politician to
cover them fairly
yeah to read their story right
apparently
again we're looking at everything
through a prism of color and eric adams
it's just so disappointing because when
he first came in
there's high hopes for him and now we're
already seeing comments that remind me
of uh one lori lightfoot you remember
her when she said she would only give
interviews to
those working in journalism in chicago
uh that are journalists of color and and
that's quite the insult to the asian
journalists out there the hispanic
journalists out there and yes the white
journalists out there maybe we take
questions from all journalists have we
thought about that so that that's what
we're seeing here at this point uh mayor
adams uh again
you gotta quote martin luther king jr
here judge somebody uh by the content of
their character not the color of their
skin uh but he's playing this game that
we see far too often on cnn and msnbc
and it's it's disappointing just to
repeat that again and to reiterate the
coverage that he's received from every
media outlet has been pretty darn good
he should be pretty happy but
he's clearly not let's get to this
msnbc's chris hayes getting mocked after
he falsely claimed that donald trump
received illegal donations from the
united arab emirates when it was in fact
the clinton campaign that received them
joe is this story from durham really
getting back under all these guys skin
making them unable to focus and making
unforced errors
it's remarkable that whenever donald
trump makes a big claim that it gets
rejected outright as an absolute
conspiracy theory right we're all old
enough to remember uh when trump and tom
cotton said that kovac could have come
from a lab in wuhan uh and that was
dismissed as oh that's that's that's a
conspiracy theory and it was even
squashed online if you even shared
stories about it i'm old enough to
remember hunter biden
and we were told that the contents of
his laptop were misinformation turns out
they were not and now we're seeing it
here with the durham probe from people
like chris hayes and many others uh in
journalism saying that no there is no
story here whatsoever but let's play a
game of can you imagine right let's say
a prosecutor with credibility so high
that he is respected on both sides of
the aisle found that donald trump's
campaign had spied on his democratic
opponent both as a candidate and a
sitting president you really think the
new york times washington post cnn all
the major broadcast news networks would
dismiss that story uh no no they would
be wall to wall there would be no
commercials on those other channels they
would have so much to say that's good
joe koncha had a lot to say today we
appreciate it thanks joe thanks joe hi
winner brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe
right now